bueno en el segundo proyecto seguramente
no tendrá prácticamente debate lo mismo
que en diputados pasará sin mayor
discusión hay un acuerdo y un concepto
absoluto sobre la necesidad de acompañar
a las mujeres que deciden seguir con el
embarazo el debate fuerte va a estar
como fue en 2018 en el senado en torno
al proyecto de interrupción legal del
embarazo que les quiere permitir a las
mujeres decidir si continuar o no
libremente con un embarazo y si desean
abortar que el estado los prestadores
privados resuelvan esa práctica y se la
y se la otorguen de manera gratuita y en
forma rápida como para que no tenga que
perder tiempo bueno el diputados lo
aprobó como en 2018 y ahora en 2020 otra
vez en el senado no está claro que los
votos estén garantizados para que sea
aprobado a pesar de que es un proyecto
que fue enviado por el ejecutivo que la
presidenta del senado es la
vicepresidenta cristina fernández y que
el partido de gobierno la alianza de
gobierno tiene mayoría en el senado
veremos qué ocurre finalmente entre hoy
y mañana con la votación gracias a
natalio por este reporte